you wonder why you're single decade
after decade it's because you don't
prioritize your relationships first one
you don't attract [ __ ] into your life
and it's not the universe's fault you
probably just suck at boundaries
i was probably i was probably a little
bit bitter on twitter
when i wrote this one it's just like all
these contrarian [ __ ]
thinking they're so much smarter than
everybody else
so you are as much of a fan of truth
bombs and red pills and uncomfortable
insights as
i am so what i've done is i've scraped
your social media from the last few
months
and pulled out some of the best ones and
i've kept some absolute corkers for the
end
but before we get into going through
those you're writing a book with will
smith
are you producing releasing a book with
will smith
yeah so i mean my part's kind of over um
but yeah he he and i linked up in 2018
he wanted to write uh kind of a memoir
slash
life lessons kind of from his career in
his life
uh and he was looking for a co-author
and so he and i just hit it off
had good chemistry um and it was
i was i you know i was a little bit
hesitant
at first you know i was like i don't
want to do this just because it's a
celebrity
you know i don't want to be part of like
a pr puff piece
um you know it needs to be real it needs
to be raw like there needs to be a good
reason
behind it and when i met him for the
first time
i asked him why he wanted to do a book
he the first thing he said is he said
look like
my whole career i've been like hiding
myself
um you know as a as a huge celebrity
like you hide yourself from the world
you like
everything is polished and pristine
and kind of catered for the viewer um
he was like i want i want to put the
real me out there
and um i was like [ __ ] yeah dude
i'm on board
what's it like working with will smith
honestly man he is uh he's a dream
like he and i've heard this is not the
case with a lot of famous people but
he he is honestly one of the easiest
people to work with he's really
professional he's
super nice um very smart
very down the earth we honestly like we
just had a blast
like we just we just hung out
he took me all these crazy [ __ ]
places that he was going to
and uh and we just sit around and like
talk about his life and talk about his
ideas and
it it was easy for me because i just i
just sat there and listened
and then i got i like basically just
pick out like his greatest hits you know
like
like oh that that's a really good one
we'll use that you know and
um so that was it you know and then i
did the first draft and that and
he's done the uh he kind of did a
revision
of that oh that's cool so you you sort
of ghost
wrote it and he edited his own work kind
kind of
yeah like we did the outline together
and
and kind of came up like agreed on the
structure and then i
i did that the first draft which is
generally the more agonizing draft
and uh and then yeah and then he kind of
revised his voice onto it and
added little details and you know style
stylistic things and stuff like that so
uh it's great i'm super excited i'm
excited for him
um i'm excited for me like it's it's a
really cool book
and um uh i'm proud of it
so it comes out november 9th right
that's it come on pre-order link
it'll be i'll make sure the pre-order
links in the show notes below um
yeah i think more sort of
heroes of hollywood you know obviously
mcconaughey released his green lights
this year and that's absolutely smashed
it and
kind of added value it wasn't just a as
you said this sort of puff piece about
i'm a rich
famous person you should find out about
my life like it's actually adding
genuine value and
yeah i mean i'd i'd learn [ __ ] from will
smith
i feel like i've got stuff yeah
he's got a lot to share man did he
impact given the fact that you've sort
of learned a lot about this world
sense making and kind of understanding
the way that the world works
did he impart sort of lessons or change
your worldview profoundly at all he was
very impactful on me
in in kind of a slightly different way i
mean i'll say this when i met him
and he really started sharing his story
like his childhood and
growing up in west philly and you know
like being a rapper in the
in the 80s like it
i quickly realized that this is one of
the most
emotionally resilient people i've ever
met like the
the stuff that he went through um
and and not only like went through it
but surmounted it
and then came out the other side like a
positive healthy person
um it's just incredible like it's it's a
real
there's a real kind of survivorship
aspect to his story
that i think most people don't know
about him like people don't realize that
um and so that really excited me
from kind of a writing standpoint and
you know being in the personal
development world like that's
you know we kind of like live and
breathe stories like that um
so i'm super excited about that but in
terms of like how he affected me
personally actually most of what i
learned from him was very much
uh kind of like professional based you
know like um
seeing the way he built his team
and the way he thinks about you know
creative
projects or collaborating with people
seeing the way he deals with his fans
um kind of just hearing his ideas of
like
on just you know being famous or being a
thought leader or being somebody who
people like being a role model
um you know this is a guy who's done
that at the highest level for
30 years now and so for me you know i'm
still a fairly young guy my career just
kind of took off
four or five years ago um it was like a
master class
of just you know how to like be a
professional in a creative industry
and um and how to like handle success
well
and maintain success and and work with
people
it was great that really is pretty
invaluable right because
as you get further and further up the
totem pole of success and away from the
normal distribution of normal right
there's who the [ __ ] teaching mark
manson how to deal with fame
you know like the guy the guy that sold
13 million books like who's
who's the one that's like oh yeah i'm
five steps ahead of you mate like you
know hold on to the coattails good luck
there's a very very small number of
people that can do that and i think
um i heard recently rogan had a reverse
interview
with uh i can't remember the pair
they're really good podcasters actually
they sat him down in his own studio and
and interviewed him and you find out he
he has the same challenges and
you're talking about probably perhaps
the most influential person in america
one of and he's like i've got a [ __ ]
clue what i'm doing he doesn't even have
a pa
like you just realize everyone and again
that's that's quite an interesting thing
or a humbling thing for normal people
normal to realize right that look
the people that you care about and think
have got it all sorted out they're just
[ __ ] about as well
like they haven't got a clue no one's
got a clue like if will smith's
like the if you have to get to will
smith's level to have your [ __ ] sorted
there's no hope for any of us well it's
funny too because it's you know at this
point i've spent
three years around him and his team and
i i mean i love his the people on his
he's got great people who work for him
and and i i really like them
but it's funny because i mean they have
the exact same challenges
of like any business organization that
you would ever come
you know it's like the same kind of
[ __ ] and miscommunication
and like you know like egos bumping into
each other and stuff and it's
having got the designs done on time and
too many emails and can somebody set
such and such up with the ssn3p
server and all that [ __ ] exactly
exactly
you know it's funny i've got a i've got
a friend here in new york who's kind of
he's uh he's pretty high up in the the
vc world
here and um and he kind of he just had
like kind of a
stratospheric rise in in his career in
the last five years
as well and i remember i was talking to
him so suddenly he's
taking meetings with like high-level
people at
you know he's getting invited out to
like you know meet with ceos of fortune
500 companies
and you know being brought on like as a
consultant
you know because it's like this huge
company is thinking about
doing an internal incubator for a bunch
of startups within
and they they need advice on like what's
the best way to go about it so he's like
meeting all these like ceos and
billionaires and stuff and i remember i
was having dinner with him
and he was like yeah i just i think i
realized
you know i always just thought like if i
just go one rung higher like everybody's
gonna know what they're doing
and now i'm like at the top of the
ladder and it's just
it's morons all the way down
she's like nobody has a clue man it's
like it's it's the difference between
the top and you know maybe like
how you know slightly above average is
maybe you're like you're five percent
more of a clue
you know that's probably it
[ __ ] well i mean i've been thinking
about this a lot recently
how many times do you have to disprove
your own imposter syndrome
with success in the real world before it
[ __ ] off for good
like what's the nail in the coffin of
that is it
14 million but is it 15 million books is
it like
i'm not there yet seventeen set like
seven million email subscribers like
eight million
like where does it stop yeah i mean i if
there's
if there's ever a number that
uh brings total confidence
i have not found it yet
and it's you know what and it's funny
too because
i i you know i've still i think i've got
my imposter syndrome's gotten a little
bit better
um you know i i i think any time you
have a sudden
burst of success you know imposter
syndrome is probably like a normal
healthy reaction because there's a
little bit of like a whoa what the [ __ ]
what did i do to deserve this you know
like that it's kind of a natural
and then you start settling into it
realize um
that that you know you worked pretty
hard and you you did something great
um but like i still have some of it but
it's funny i feel like
part of me is a little bit afraid to let
go because i feel like if i if i let go
and i'm like yeah i'm mark [ __ ]
manson
my books like crush it you know
as soon as i if i let myself fall into
that
then i i just feel like it's gonna
backfire so hard
so it's almost like um it's almost like
there's like an optimal amount of
insecurity
yeah um people use you know let's say
people people
like a little is better than none i
think yeah yeah
i would i would say that that's not a
bad way to look at it people use
imposter syndrome as a proxy for
humbleness sometimes
um it's actually manifest in a really
sort of similar way
um and if it kind of constrains your ego
perhaps the if the outcome is worthy
perhaps that's a way to look at it seth
godin said to me
that um if you're doing something that
you've never done before
or that maybe no one's ever done before
of course you've got imposter syndrome
why wouldn't you
by definition you're breaking new ground
you're in
an area of the terrain that you haven't
yet you haven't yet explored
yeah and and i think there's also
there's kind of like um
like a more philosophical element to it
to you know it's
i know so many smart authors who work
so [ __ ] hard and like they write
great books
and so there's a little bit of like a
why me like
you know kind of a survivorship guilt
type thing yeah almost like it's it's
like
like i think my my books are good but
they're not like
you know 50x better than like this other
guy
you know but so why do i get 50x the
result like that doesn't
there's something that just seems like
strange about that
um so yeah it's weird
it's a weird thing right okay
uncomfortable truths
first one you don't attract [ __ ] into
your life
and it's not the universe's fault you
probably just suck at boundaries
[Laughter]
um oh that's a good one i like that one
i really do as well but i don't talk
about so here's the thing man i don't
really talk about boundaries that much
it's never really been one of those
terms that i've
brought into my lexicon of normal daily
sense making use so what are you talking
about what sort of boundaries
so in terms of boundaries um
i mean in terms of i usually use them in
relation to relationships
um but it's it's basically like
understanding what you
will and will not tolerate in your life
and
um and i think a lot of people kind of
get
you know the stuff that i mentioned
there you know believing the universe is
giving you something
blah blah like a lot of these ideas
about like law of attraction or whatever
they kind of get close to that
you know a lot of attraction tells you
like you know whatever you think about
that's what you like manifest in your
reality well it's more like
your expectations tend to partially
dictate your behavior and then your
behavior is going to partially dictate
your reality and uh and so if you're
expecting to get screwed over
all the time then uh you're going to
behave in such a way in which
you kind of invite it into your life and
and where
and where this is just fundamentally a
boundary issue is that if you
if you simply decide like you know i i
will not accept dishonesty in my life
and
i'm going to like enforce that boundary
by like actually eliminating people who
are dishonest from
being around me um you know like that's
actually a healthy way to manage your
life it has nothing to do with the
universe it has nothing to do with like
laws of attraction or vibrations or
energy or whatever it's like
it's simply making a decision it's
deciding like
this is something i don't want in my
life so i'm not going to allow it
um and it's it's like
it's such a simple concept but we we
struggle so much
with it like it's a very it's one of
those things that it's very easy to
understand but incredibly
difficult to um actually like enforce
well unless you've taken the full
non-dual enlightenment red pill
and you walking around part of the the
substrate of the world
you fight you feel like an actor right
you feel like an agent
that has thoughts and very much is the
center of the universe like it because
you are
everything emanates out and comes toward
you even the light you know the sun
doesn't shine anywhere except for on you
as far as you're concerned and um yeah i
think as well
think about how the reticular activating
system works like
if you tell some as soon as you buy a
new car you always notice that new car
everywhere
everyone's got this car no you're just
looking out for it and the same goes
with this like if you prime someone this
is what
guys like darren brown and these other
sort of quasi-illusionists
mind mental melding people do right they
just prime people
and then they put them into a situation
and the brain does the rest
yeah yeah i mean it's it's our
our perceptions are highly inaccurate
and they're very much
uh they're very much affected by the
nature of our thoughts and
you don't need a magical explanation for
that they're like very logical
scientific explanations for that
um but it's you know i think what
matters is that people adapt their
behavior to it
ultimately next one stop taking things
personally
it's rarely about you
yeah i think this is this kind of harks
back to what you just said about
uh everybody's the center of their own
universe you know like we all
we all experience everything through
the lens of our of our own physical
experience and so it's it's kind of our
default
you know david foster wallace has this
great passage in his speech this is
water where he
he talks about like everything that we
experience it's happening
it's experience like relative to us
you know it's impossible to experience
something as somebody else and so our
default
setting psychologically is to assume
that
until proven otherwise everything
involves us where this is just like a
highly inaccurate
assumption and um
and i it's just something that i've
always i've found helpful throughout my
life
um especially you know it's something i
really realized back
when i was young and i was dating you
know like i i'd go to a party or
something and start chatting with a girl
and
she'd kind of blow me off and you know
the natural reaction is to just assume
like wow i'm such a loser
like if i was a cool guy like every girl
would just
immediately want to go home with me and
it's like no man like you don't know
what she's going through you don't know
where she is in her life like maybe she
just got dumped maybe
she's seen somebody else maybe she's
leaving town tomorrow and never coming
back like
you know it's not only do you not know
but it's also none of your [ __ ]
business
it's like get get out of your own
ass and and uh you know empathize a
little bit
well we'd never claim that for ourselves
right if somebody said why did you cut
me up in traffic you'd say oh well i was
late for this thing or i do whatever but
when it's someone else the fundamental
attribution error kicks in
and you think yeah that guy did it
because he's a prick but i did it yeah i
did it because i'm late for work and
they should understand yeah yeah so i
mean it's like when you when you reject
somebody it's like
you know you're thinking you're like i
just don't really have time like meet
somebody new right now
but when they reject it's like oh i'm
such a media
she's a [ __ ] she's so selfish
[Laughter]
it really is always about you right man
this is i really enjoy this one so
you can't get far alone and another one
if you think it's you against the world
chances are
it's just you against yourself
yeah yeah i think um
one thing
i i think look look like the world's an
incredibly complicated place
and i talk about this in my book
everything is [ __ ] is that like
the world is sure the world's [ __ ] but
the world's always been [ __ ] and it's
always gonna be [ __ ] like there's no
pick a place in history where things
were were okay like there's literally
not a single moment in history that
things were okay
and so it's just i i think just conflict
and strife and corruption like these are
just natural states of
human society and and i i've just found
through the years and through experience
and and talking to a lot of people that
um generally like the more zealous
a person is about some sort of like
global cause about saving the world and
uh you know ridding the world of evil
um usually the more [ __ ] up that
person is themselves
you know like the the more dysfunctional
their own life is
the more dysfunctional their own
relationships more you know the more
dysfunctional their own uh you know
ability to accomplish goals or get
something done
like there seems to me to be like a
one-to-one relationship between those
two things
um so i just think it's we tend to
like when you become comfortable with
your own flaws
and shortcomings you tend to be more
comfortable with the world's flaws and
shortcomings
and what about not being able to get far
alone obviously as a guy that was quite
self-sufficient
dating and that sort of early life and
stuff like that
what happened there how did you make
that kind of pivot
um i just found that you know
wherever you get alone it doesn't it's
it feels kind of meaningless
um for some reason
you know and i think there's probably an
evolutionary explanation for this but
it's
accomplishments isolated accomplishments
um feel very superficial whereas like
group accomplishments feel very profound
and meaningful you know it feels much
more powerful
to do something as a team or to do
something for a family
or to do something for your your partner
uh than it does to just you know collect
accolades for yourself
i had jordan peterson on the show and we
talked about how to deal with the pain
of losing friends as you get older you
grow
people drop away the ones that were part
of your life and um
it really struck me some of the comments
from people and i think this perhaps
skews just because youtube generally
invites a type of audience that's maybe
a little bit more introspective and
and doing that kind of self-inquiry and
perhaps is used to solitude in any case
but i was really surprised at how many
people were um
not bitter but were a little resentful
at the world
and were kind of saying i don't need
anybody
i can make it on my own friends just
slow me down
uh a lot a lot of sort of bits and
pieces of feedback like this and i
thought
that's interesting because these people
have come because they know my content
and jordan's as well i don't i don't
think that either of us
have really pushed that sort of a
rhetoric if anything i've
both of us have said try as hard as you
can to find relationships that make you
feel good
and this is something that's interesting
where people like to talk about leaning
into discomfort and finding the struggle
and overcoming obstacles and stuff like
that
but those are only within quite a
narrowly defined domain
it's like i'll deal with the struggles
but i'll deal with them
in the gym or i'll deal with them in
business or i'll deal with them
financially or i'll deal with them
existentially or whatever it might be
and then you pull people outside of that
and it seems like it correlates
or there is a um significant minority
of people for whom one of the areas of
discomfort that perhaps
they're less comfortable with being
uncomfortable in
is building relationships
yeah it's um i used to be like that and
um i just found
it was funny because it you know like i
just said it's like the more the further
i did get by myself
the more pointless it seemed and um
and the more i started to you know kind
of
lament my my isolation my social
isolation and
i you know one of my biggest discoveries
in my adult life
is what you just said about like taking
that
same willingness to lean into discomfort
in other areas of my life to to
sacrifice and make commitments for my
business you know the
sacrifice make commitments for my health
or for my writing
like apply that to to personal
relationships like sacrifice and make
commitments to
to my friends to my wife um to my kids
if i have them like
and as soon as i stepped into that it's
like the most meaningful and
profound thing you can have like it
makes everything else seem
very trivial very quickly um
but it's hard to explain that to people
and i think a lot of people who are in
that place they're probably like me
where they've
you know their history like i had never
really had like a healthy
close relationship with somebody and
until my
probably late twenties um you know my
family was
quite dysfunctional a lot of my
friendships had
let me down my early relationships were
very
toxic and dysfunctional um
so it's it's something that you can't
really see until you get there
but and it's so it's hard to describe
the people who aren't there
but um it's i mean if there's anything
uh
you know i believe and i know peterson
believes very very strongly like it's
it's just
there's really no point unless you're
there's really no point in doing
anything unless you're you're doing it
for
for some something greater than yourself
what's the first step for something like
that or can you remember this
first step that you took to transition
you know i i think
i think there's there's a lot of
there's a certain amount of inner work
that kind of has to happen first
a certain amount of um
dealing with you know your own uh pain
and beliefs
and emotions you know i i had to reach a
certain level of like emotional
maturity to you know and that's not to
say that everybody who feels this way is
emotionally immature like
people have different levels of needs
but like
for me it was i was carrying around a
lot of resentment
and um and i there was also a lot of
like i took a lot of pride in being
being able to like do things on my own
you know the fact that i could pick up
and go to another country for like three
months
and not tell a soul and
people are like oh my god how did you do
that like that's terrifying you know
it's like there was a pride that i could
do that
you know but it's after a certain amount
of time you start to realize that stuff
like that is it's kind of silly it's ego
based you know and so it's silly
and at some point you just kind of have
to get over yourself
and realize that um
it's
i think i think as as you get older as
at least as i got older
you you gain enough perspective to be
able to look back and see like
wow the five years i i dedicated to that
one thing
does not feel important to me anymore
yet wow i really
i really miss my friends i haven't
talked to in five years you know
and then it starts like sinking in might
be something to this
right next one next one you're
overthinking it because you assume
you're more special than others
um now i i'll add a caveat to that see
this is the problem with social media
is and this you always get in trouble
with this on social media because it's
you tried it like social media is
optimized for pithiness
narrow bandwidth thing yeah and uh
you know as when you compress
things like that obviously you start
losing accuracy
um so stuff like this i'll always get in
trouble because people will reply those
well it's not the only reason you
overthink things well yeah you're right
it's not the only reason you overthink
things but
but often it's um it's a reason you you
overthink things
um you know i think there's
there's something anxiety itself
uh and i'm trying to think of a way to
say this
that's not gonna sound absolutely
horrible um
there's there's a fundamental
selfishness that kind of comes attached
with anxiety
um because when you're anxious
it very much and it's involuntary it's
not it's not that you're a bad person or
that you are a selfish person but it's
there's an involuntary kind of
selfishness that comes
packaged with anxiety and that you
become overly preoccupied with
yourself and you know it's it's this
you kind of become obsessed with like oh
what does he think about me or
did the thing i say was that stupid or
um
am i going to be a failure or is anybody
ever going to like me and it's it's
always me me me i i i
and um there's a real kind of just
you know i found you know kind of
dealing with some of my own social
anxiety in the past
um there's a really profound effect of
of
if you're able to like invert that focus
um and and
kind of turn it more into compassion or
empathy for others
start worrying about like wondering what
they're worried about you know it's like
if you're
if you're like the anxious mess in a
crowded room
uh who doesn't know anybody like maybe
look around and wonder like
it you know is it other people are
likely feeling similar things um
and it's just that that simple ability
to kind of step outside of yourself is
it often alleviates um
you know it removes that sense of
specialness it removes that like i'm the
only one who feels this way i'm the only
one suffering this way i'm the only one
who
understands what it's like
um and you start realizing that
everybody else like has very similar
problems or is thinking very similar
things or worried about similar things
you no longer feel alone in that
suffering well the common
thought raiser is if you have a thought
assume that at least some other
significant minority of people also have
it
but the way that our emotions feel right
they're like
they're like bestowed on us like curses
individual diseases that have just been
given purely to us by some higher power
and this is why when you actually think
about how emotions feel
almost all of the stories that kind of
ancient religions
spoke about you know thinking about how
the goddess of lust and
and envy and anger and stuff like that
like of course it makes sense because
it feels like it's so much more the
phenomenon of having an emotion
is so much more than just the wiring
going on in your brain
yeah and that leads us to have that kind
of very
self-focused neurotic
uh view of the world right yeah
yeah and it's it's interesting too
because if you generally if you
look at all the negative emotions the
negative emotions are very self-focused
you know so anger is always like this
horrible you know i'm
i need to you know i need to this
horrible thing happened to me and now
i'm angry you know
anxiety is this horrible thing's going
to happen to me
guilt is this horrible happen thing
happened to me in the past
um whereas if you look at positive
emotions it's very outwardly focused
it's very much you know happiness or joy
it's
it's it's kind of this like gratitude
for
the place you're in the people you're
with the the experiences you had
um and i i don't think that's a
coincidence so
i think that that's you know there's a
fundamental connection between those two
psychological phenomenon and it's
probably
not not expressed super well in a
in a pithy tweet
[Laughter]
all right next one uh the more we seek
change
the more meaningless that change becomes
i didn't understand this one
yeah this one didn't go this one didn't
go over so well this was one of those
ones that i looked at afterwards and i'm
like uh yeah i probably could explain
this better
uh now's your chance you know i i would
say
change isn't the right word i think
novelty is the right word
um i was trying to kind of make a point
about
thrill seeking or novelty seeking you
know it's it's
there's a diminishing returns to novelty
seeking you know it's like
the the example i always use is like the
the first time you go to a foreign
country it's like this huge
not like life-changing experience um
even like the 10th foreign country you
go to is like a very exciting
experience but uh you know country
number
62 is kind of like oh okay
sure whatever um you you
you require generally anything that
drives kind of a sense of novelty or
excitement
requires like greater and greater
quantities of that experience to
um to kind of get the same the same
feeling
you know whether that's travel or
cocaine
or sexual partners or
money you know whatever it is
social book sales social media followers
you know it's like
whatever it is whatever that dopamine
hit
is um there's always a diminishing
returns to it so it so it
they they make for poor long-term
strategies the hedonic treadmills are a
hell of a drug man
absolute hell of a drug right to deny
negative emotions is to ignore useful
feedback
from the world so i wanted to ask how
much
we should notice our negative emotions
if they're good teachers because
buddhism would instruct us to not
identify with them
and some of the good elements of
stoicism which i know you have
criticisms of would also
suggest detachment don't fixate or
suppress
you know how can you
avoid denying negative emotions to
acquire the lessons from them but then
also not identify with them too much
that seems like a little bit of an
oxymoron
yeah i mean i i i
definitely subscribe to kind of the
buddhism slash stoicism school
thought of like notice emotions but
don't
don't be dictated by them um
and i i think it's you know one of the
things i'm highly critical of
uh you know kind of the whole positive
thinking
self-help genre is sub-genre is is that
it it's
it often gets interpreted by people as
as like a simple denial of negativity
you know it's like pretending like
everything's great you know
it's like the dog in the in the burning
house like this is fine
there's so many uses for it it's
endlessly useful
it is um you know so
so the goal is is to not deny
you know i people generally have two
problems around negative emotions is
either they they deny it in the first
place
or they indulge it they kind of live in
it
you know so um they they experience
their fear or they experience their
anger but they like
latch onto it and don't let it go um and
so the trick is to be open to it but
also
part of being open is to let it leave
once it's ready to leave
but i generally you know the the
argument i always use
for kind of the denier positive thinking
crowd is i always i i say like negative
emotions like they have
they evolve for a reason like they have
survival
purposes um you know and so if you don't
like if you train yourself to never be
afraid of anything like you you're
you're gonna put yourself in some pretty
dangerous situations pretty quickly
right next one just because your
contrarian
doesn't mean you're smart
[Laughter]
i love this one i i mean i was probably
i was probably a little bit bitter on
twitter when i wrote this one
it's just like all these contrarian
[ __ ] thinking they're so much
smarter than everybody else
um
you know speaking of mcconaughey like
mcconaughey had a uh
one of the parts i really liked about
mcconaughey's book is he had this whole
section where he was talking about how
like
you need to know the rules before you
can break the rules um
which you know i when i was young i was
that i was that guy who just broke every
rule i'm like rules are stupid i'm gonna
break every single one and
um you quickly realize that rules exist
for a reason and i think
the same thing can be said for
institutions
it can be said for cultural norms um
it can be said for uh you know
manners or language like these things
they they evolve and they exist for a
reason and so if you're gonna break them
you need to have a good reason that
doesn't mean they're always right but
like
the default assumption should be that
they're right it should
the default assumption should not be
that they're not right um
and so it's it's correct until proven
wrong not the other way around
well i mean how much are we seeing this
with the current debate over the covered
vaccine
like yeah i mean the most apparently the
smartest people on the internet are the
ones that have this
super secret gate kept knowledge with
regards to
the covered vaccine you think 50 of
americans have had their first dose and
66 percent of british citizens
have had their first dose uh here's the
thing that i found out which is [ __ ]
brilliant man
only 20 of the uk population is on
twitter
so even when you think what everybody
thinks this
even if you were to max out everyone on
twitter
to get agreement you've only got 20 of
the uk
population what the [ __ ] yeah yeah i
i i actually just wrote an article about
social media
a couple weeks ago and i talked about
this like it's really fascinating when
they analyze social networks they tend
to find kind of the same distribution
of users and they call it the
the 1990 rule which is basically
one percent of the users generate 90 of
the content
nine percent of the users generate 10
of the content and then 90 of the users
generate
basically no content whatsoever like
they're just they're observers
and if you ask yourself like okay who
are the one percent generating the 90
of content like it's a large percentage
of those people are
the [ __ ] crackpots and nut cases
you know it trolls and it's um
you know it's one of the one of the big
take-home points in that article was
like
like everybody needs to learn
that social media is not reality social
i call it like social media is a fun
house mirror of reality
it reflects reality but it's different
parts are elongated and exaggerated and
other parts are kind of minimized and
you know so it's and and i i think it's
we're not especially kind of people in
the media um
or people who read a lot of news or you
know follow the media very closely like
a lot of people have not figured that
out yet like this is not
um it's not reality it's it's a
it's a really skewed version of it but
yeah i mean
coming from being like an online brand
or whatever
myself you know one thing i learned very
early on
early on in my career is like if you
want clicks like just be contrarian
like you know it's like i it's kind of
how i got my start as a blogger like
i write an article called like you know
you are not special and sure enough you
would get a shitload of clicks
and i'd write another one saying like
you know [ __ ] positive thinking
get a ton of clicks um you know so it's
disagreeing with something or tearing
something down is
a great way to get attention like our
you know coming back to the human
perception thing like we are very biased
to notice
flaws and negativity much more easily or
like give it more attention or more
importance than
um things that are functioning correctly
um
and the fact of the matter is is like if
you want to find individual flaws or
failures or inaccuracies and pretty much
every institution in the world like you
can find plenty of them they're run by
humans so like of course you're gonna
find plenty of them
but that doesn't mean we need to like
overthrow the world order or like
take down the government take down the
cdc
or the fda or like destroy the the fed
like all this [ __ ] that people this like
like
legit revolutionary conclusions that
these people are coming to
um is is a disproportionate response to
to the actual flaws in the system that
they're exposed to
yeah it needs to be iteration i think
there's this donald noth quote which i
always come back to and he says
tradition is a set of solutions for
which we have forgotten
the problems yes for sure
and you just think if it's that what
fence in a field
analogy um which now actually i don't
think works you know there's a fence in
the field and the liberal goes up to it
and says we just need to tear this down
the conservative goes well hang on a
second we don't know why it's there
it might function might have a purpose i
don't think that that divide occurs
anymore
i think that both groups are now looking
for revolution by
by any means i don't actually know who
is pro
institution anymore both sides have
problems with the same things for
completely opposing reasons but the
solution is the same tear it down
it all needs to [ __ ] off um yeah it's an
intro it's like
it's like it's like the rights like
let's take a chainsaw to it the left is
like [ __ ] chainsaws let's blow it up
nuclear pump yeah precisely
you know and they're just arguing
they're like chainsaws bomb
chainsaws but uh but the funny thing is
is like this comes back to like the
social media not being reality it's like
there's a silent majority of people who
do believe in the institutions
they're just not on [ __ ] twitter like
they're taking care of their kids
they're going
even the silent majority on twitter
probably also does
as well and then yeah on
right okay okay okay next one next one
um the secret
to success is pain tolerance do you not
think that success can be easy
then no
no if it was easy then everybody would
have it then it wouldn't be success
um because success is by definition
something that is
is uh um you know
on the extreme uh [ __ ] what's the word
i'm looking for um
it's something that's that that's you
know extraordinary means something that
is not ordinary it's like beyond
ordinariness so
it's it if you're getting the same
result everybody else got then it's not
it's not success it's not uh and i
suppose that the success is a function
of the discomfort to get there as well
right the satisfaction of getting to a
higher mountain
is greater than that of getting to a
smaller mountain because of the
challenge that it took you to get to the
top
absolutely i mean it's people like
like if you went and climbed mount
everest and i went and climbed like
whatever shitty hill is in upstate new
york like you know who's
who's gonna be more impressed
it's it's it's just it's just how it
works
right this one this one i really like
the only way to become truly confident
in yourself is to be comfortable with
what you lack
yep yeah confidence is not
hiding what we lack it's not even and
it's not even exposing what we have it's
it's it's a comfort and a calmness about
our shortcomings and valence because we
all got them
it's just it's our relationship to them
that kind of determines our
our mental health i was speaking to
a special forces operative british one
and he was talking about how all of the
guys use
quite morbid humor to get
past these scary situations and it's
this pressure release valve because all
of them are [ __ ] themselves all of
them are scared
it's like if you don't think that we're
scared you're wrong but we just have
ways of coping with it
and most of them coped with it by making
jokes
about stuff by laughing by laughing
about stuff one guy got
a shot like a single pellet from a
shotgun or something went through the
meat of his ass cheek and all of them
couldn't stop laughing about it
and this guy's got to have
like he's off work but he's off like off
the unit for god knows how long and he's
got to have stitches and all of these
operations to get it fixed
and he was laughing and so is everyone
else
yeah man gallows humor yeah but it's
it's you're right as well that
confidence from most people isn't due to
a
uh presumed lack of capacity it's due to
an uh exaggerated um presence
of insufficiency yeah
and embracing that is the solution
yeah and i i think it's it's easy to
mistake
um you know there there's
a lot of people in the world compensate
for their
their lack or their flaws by
overly boasting about their successes or
or their
positive traits and um
and i think people
people wrongly attribute that to
confidence you know if somebody's like
i'm the best
so and so ever i'm the best mountain
climber ever like man that guy's
confident it's like no it's actually
quite the opposite you know it's it's he
has to say that
or else he doesn't feel comfortable
actually going and doing it you know
if he was confident he wouldn't have to
say it it's like a you know
where i grew up we have a group in texas
we have a lot of
corny southern sayings and one of them
is uh the the smallest dog is barks the
loudest
and um it's like yeah if you've got a
if you got to tell everybody you're rich
you're not rich
like you got to tell somebody if you got
to tell everybody how smart you are
you're not smart
you know you either are you or you
aren't
right we're into the meat of it now this
is this is my favorite section
so if all your relationships have the
same problem
you are the problem
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah um how did this one get it
[Laughter]
you know you know what's funny so this
was originally i wrote a short article
um i wrote a short article i think in
like 2012 or 13 and it was called uh
it was called like all the reasons
you're still single
and um
and i published it on valentine's day
and uh
you know i just got like a sick pleasure
out of that you know it basically said
it was like look all these problems you
think all your partners have or all the
people you date have like guess what you
know the only thing they have in common
is
common to nominate um but i i repost
that
probably about once a year in different
places and different valentine's day
just let's schedule it every february
14th from now until the end of time
i i had a pretty sick thing going on my
blog with valentine's day for a while
like
like i did that one year and then i
think the next year i did like a how to
break up with somebody
like guide on valentine's day i did like
a bunch of like kind of [ __ ] up uh
you know dark humor type things but um
yeah i repost that one quite frequently
because
um i mean i always get
a lot of people get mad at me when i
post it a lot of you know because
everybody's got that
well you don't understand my ex is
different you know
what all four of them have the exact
same problem that you
you happen to be the single thread but
they don't know each other they're not
even in the same city
and yet they all ended in the same way
but it's all their fault not yours
it's it's always i'm always uh you know
i
so i get lots and lots of emails over
the years and
and i'm always amused that the people
who get really upset
at my relationship advice they're
they always send emails like this long
and it's always like well
you understand my situation is different
and then they go on the tell this like
you know five stage five-page sob story
about
you know god knows what uh the
and in every in every case it's it's
exactly the same it's like no you're
you're still the problem
you're just you know um
but yeah it's also i keep posting it
because it is such a powerful
realization
um it was very powerful in my own life
uh and i've you know just heard from
hundreds of people at this point who
told me the same thing that it was very
powerful for them to hear as well
so i i'm willing to deal with a little
bit of hate um
to get the good word out doing god's
work uh right
lots of people who are still single but
want a relationship
simply have absurd expectations
yes i i think one of the problems with
uh i mean look like i think one of the
side effects of
of the internet like kind of the effects
that the internet has had on cultures
that
it's exposed us to the most
extraordinary aspects
of society you know so it's
if you're interested in uh you know
mountain climbing you can like go on
youtube and find
amazing videos of people summoning
everest like left right and center and
so
i i feel like this is without us
realizing it has skewed our expectations
for our own lives
um it's kind of like moved the goal back
about 50 yards
from where it would normally be without
us necessarily even recognizing it
and i think this applies to dating as
well it's like you you
because you have access to so many
people through dating apps or online or
or whatever um you you
start developing these kind of
unrealistic standards of what a partner
should be
you know people develop these insane
checklists
of you know well they they need to be
like
they need to be a concert pianist and
they need to have a phd
and they need to be a part-time model
and they need to
speak six languages and you know it's
like
good luck man like good luck
uh so i i just i think sometimes we need
to be brought down to earth
i wonder whether as well
part of it is just that we we
constantly are looking for something
that's going to fill the hole
and perhaps by setting our standards so
absurdly high we never actually have to
enter the world of
a relationship with people also here's
another thing man
how much do you think this is because we
live in a meritocracy
like if you teach people that they can
become anything that they want to be
your success is completely yours to bear
why shouldn't
everyone want to try and date angelina
jolie well i can
become anything i want to be i can date
anyone i want to want
yeah i i think it's
there there's kind of a missing counter
narrative to meritocracy or
not counter but like a kind of a
parallel narrative that needs to exist
where it's like
at some point you need to to like pick
your spot to be satisfied
what's the hill that you're gonna get
married on yeah exactly exactly
exactly like it's and and this comes
back to what we were talking about
earlier about like this
this kind of unwillingness to sacrifice
and commit for others like it's
the thing that makes a relationship
strong
is the ability to be like okay i see
what's wrong with you
but i'm gonna love you anyways like that
like
getting to that point is what makes the
relationship
work um but i just think like
fundamentally the way the incentives
and culture is set up right now it's
like it's it's harder than ever for
people to get to that point
yeah you classed yourself as an ardent
zealot of marriage
um have you got any advice for young
guys who want to kind of transition from
[ __ ] boy to fatherhood
from fuckboy to father be a good book
title it would be yeah yeah
um well i do want to say i'm not i'm i'm
not a
i'm not a zealot for marriage but like i
i think it's
underrated these days and i think
there's not enough
um people arguing for it especially
especially
in my generation um i would say
you know to make that transition it's
kind of the best piece of advice i've
come across is is asking people
you know because when you're dating a
lot of people part of the excitement
is there's so much a diversity of
dating experience like you you date
people
different backgrounds different
ethnicities different nationalities
different professions all this stuff
like it's a very exciting time to kind
of like
sample the buffet of what's out there um
but at a certain point like when you
want to get
serious the thing i always ask people is
i say like okay what are your three
non-negotiables like what are the three
things that like
you just cannot be with a person
if they don't have them and it's
i've noticed that people who really
struggle to name those three things like
they're kind of just like kind of lost
on this hamster wheel of
dating the next person who pops up on
tinder um
but like you really need to figure out
like what are your non-negotiables what
are the things that you really can't
live with out of it without in a partner
um and then figure out if those are good
non-negotiables you know there
there are bad things you can kind of put
in those three spots but generally it's
gonna be stuff like
you know honesty or trustworthiness um
you know for me intelligence is huge
like i i need to people have like a good
conversation um you know and and
for me too it's it's ambition i just
find i make
very very attracted to ambitious women i
i don't
i always get frustrated you know
whenever i dated women who weren't
super ambitious i'd get very frustrated
so it's like part of it's just
learning through the act of dating but
then once you have them
you look for those non-negotiables and
then you just don't worry about the
other things
because it's i think part of the trap of
the dating environment these days is
like you know it's like well
she's really great at these four or five
things but
you know she's got pointy elbows and
i prefer redheads and you know
she's from california and i don't want
to travel to meet her family you know
like it's
[ __ ] like that that people like you know
move on from potentially really good
relationships and so it's like
get your three non-negotiables and then
just [ __ ] forget everything else
like just just look for those three
things
what do you think people should stop
believing about relationships are there
any sort of common
myths that you think most people hold
um i think people mistake
uh i think people mistake compromise for
settling
um you know there's there's a strong
i've noticed that a lot of people
especially younger people have this
strong
like ethos of like i'm never gonna
settle like i'm not gonna settle for
somebody who like doesn't make me happy
or whatever
um and that's fine like you shouldn't
settle for
a person who you know has a like
somebody you're not attracted to
for instance um but at the same time
it's like
any functional relationship requires
compromise and compromise requires you
foregoing some of your own happiness to
create
you know more general happiness in the
among both of you in the long run and um
and i think a lot of people just mix up
those two things
you know i've i've talked to a lot of
people who who have ended relationships
for like
in my mind are just like insanely dumb
reasons you know
um it's like oh well she wanted to move
you know her uh her company wanted to
move her to another city
and i don't want to deal with that it's
like well dude you like
a month ago you were telling me how in
love you were like
he's like yeah but i don't want to
settle for somebody who like
it's just like they're not even it's
like yeah she wants me to travel there
every two months or something you know
it's like i don't have time for that
it's it's like okay this is why you're
single you're literally
you wonder why you're single decade
after decade it's because you don't
[ __ ] prioritize your relationships
it's really simple i mean think about it
man there's even
there's even um subcultures and and
lingo
around what people should and shouldn't
do
when they get that kind of pushback in a
relationship so for girls it's like
clapping back
right or for guys it's not being a simp
or not being a cook or not being like a
like a soy boy or whatever like not
being weak
and um you think like if both of these
things are happening because they're
coming at it
these are two very very polar uh
polarized types of
um approaches to relationships men want
sexual variety women want sort of
commitment
and um somehow both of them have arrived
at like the same conclusion it's the
same as the left and right thing that we
were talking about before
and the thing that i can only think
about is that
one of the things perhaps is an
increasing ubiquitousness
of people being exposed to perfect
seeming relationships on social media in
press so on and so forth
and in romance movies one of the few
places that kind of
um the the council culture mob hasn't
yet gotten to
is that most relationships should finish
with a happy ending
like and she built her business and
made a billion dollars and lived happily
ever after like that's not really
usually the way that
the story ends um sure
so i'm wondering whether or not people
again the unrealistic expectations thing
that we're talking about and kind of
this
yeah this conflation that um anything
shy of absolutely perfect is you being
taken for a ride
yeah well it's so there people have
always
and this is true of men and women but
you know in the dating realm men and
women
you see the same patterns but it plays
out with different language and
different uh it's expressed with
different language but like
everything you just listed i mean it's
basically seeing relationships as a
power game
and um one thing i've written before is
that like the definition of unhealthy
relationship
is when people see it as a power like
people perceive the relationship to be a
power struggle
it's always like who is
has more influence who is getting their
way more than the other person who is
getting what they want from the other
person
any relationship romantic friendship
business relationship any relationship
you you approach as a power game
is like a zero-sum power game it's by
definition toxic
it's gonna harm your life it's gonna
harm the other person's life even if
you're winning that power game
it's going to harm your life and it's
going to harm the other person's life
a healthy relationship is
the way i describe it is is both people
act unconditionally which is basically
like
look like we're equals we both want to
be happy we both want the other person
to be happy
so what do we need to do to make that
happen
and sometimes that might might mean you
know in the case like my wife and i
maybe that me
like maybe a couple times it means i
give up something or i don't do
something
a couple times i mean she gives up
something she doesn't do something like
there's there's no score card here
like there's no we're not keeping a it's
another transaction yeah yeah yeah
yeah we're not we're not like adding up
who gave up more when or whatever it's
like you know maybe one
if she's having a tough year maybe i
give up more that year if i'm having a
tough year in five years she gives up
more that year like it's
that you don't you don't ask those
questions
or try to count those things because
it's the act of counting itself that
undermines
the relationship um and it's funny too
because
a lot of the dating advice industry
both for men and for women focuses on
that scorecard it's like you know
there's there was a book in the 90s
called the rules
which was all about it was teaching
women
you know stuff like don't pick up the
phone the first time he calls
or um you know get up and go to the
bathroom
when the check comes or something to
make him pay it like stuff like that
um and it's basically teaching women how
to how to tally it like win more points
on the scorecard
but it doesn't realize it's teaching
them to have toxic relationships with
people and it's the same thing with the
game in 2005
with the whole pickup artist thing it's
the exact same it was teaching men how
to win
at the scorecard and look at [ __ ]
look at neil strauss now
yeah look at look at me
i mean it's and the thing is i mean neil
made it out better than most of those
guys like
it's it's i mean talk about train wreck
on top of train wreck
um so it's and i you know i was
part of that world when i was young and
it took me a couple years but i
soon figured out i'm like man this is
not gonna end well like
sure i'm getting laid a lot but like
this is not
like it's not making me happy it's not
it's not making you know the women i'm
i'm hooking up with are not happy people
like
um this is
this is a dead end i need to find a
different road that's the ultimate red
pill
about pickup artistry and kind of the
whole meninism movement at large and
then there has to be a an equivalent for
women i just don't know what it's called
um and this is why your first book
models
is i've just completed yes everyone
that's listening i've just finished the
reading list today
so there's a hundred books and that's
taken me [ __ ] ages man it took so
long
um and the only book the only book
that's specifically about dating and
pickup on there
is models and the fundamental reason is
that
pickup artistry and the female
equivalent of it
is teaching you tactics
to appear like an attractive mate but it
doesn't
make you an attractive mate like
it's the same as going to a powerlifting
competition
and wearing a secret mechanical
exoskeleton that allows you to pick the
weight up
you win you get the gold medal but
you're still not that strong and if
anyone asks you to replicate that again
you can't do it without all of the
tactics that you have
and i think pickup artistry as well
actually causes a lot of men to
lose confidence because what they see is
the chasm between
what the girl is attracted to in this
caricature the ulterior alter ego that
they've created for themselves
and who they actually think that they
are in this gap
the the um delta between those two is
[ __ ] huge yeah i mean it's
obviously it objectifies women you know
you when you treat them as
objects to be manipulated by using lines
and stories and whatever
you're objectifying them which is bad
for them
but what men don't realize is that
they're objectifying themselves
as well so it's it's they're
choosing to ignore who they really are
what they really want
what they really believe in what they're
really attracted to and instead
adopting a fake persona
adopting scripted lines a scripted
identity essentially
kind of like downloading an identity on
to themselves um
to just get this to get a
you know real world result to get like
to get laid a few times
it's like first of all not only does it
make the sex horrible
because because first of all it only
attracts women who are also hiding their
real selves who are also
don't have the confidence to to show up
authentically
um who don't who have low self-esteem
and are very needy
um so it brings
two emotionally unhealthy people
together to kind of do this performance
where at least for the pickup artists
like the i
the the goal is sex um but because sex
is such a vulnerable and intimate
experience
um it's really unenjoyable like 99
super performative yeah and it's
and so it's just you get the little ego
boost you're like okay i got laid now
um but yeah i think in the long run
it it makes guys feel very empty
um and feel very lost um and so so my
book models was very much
written i wrote it specifically to kind
of
to be like the antidote to that um
you know i i had spent some time in that
community and then
i kind of got out but i still coached
men's gave men stadium advice still
coach men
um and i just started to realize like
you know most of these guys like
their problem is not that they don't
know what to text a girl or that they
don't
know where to take her on a date you
know like that's not the pro the problem
is like they
[ __ ] they they don't believe in
themselves like they don't
they don't stand for anything they don't
have an identity like they don't they
don't have social skills like it's
you know deal with these fundamental
things first
and and the dating stuff will just take
care of itself and so
models was very much like a i felt like
there was not an emotionally healthy
uh guide to men's dating in the world
and so i wanted to write one that would
help men but also um
do it in a way that like they they don't
have to like sacrifice their self worth
is there anything that you change from
it or that you think you missed looking
back now whatever seven years
later on you thinking that would be
awesome to add that in
um i revised it twice so i revised it
once and
so it came out 2011 i revised in 2012
and most of that revision was kind of
just
making it getting rid of typos like
making it a little bit professional
because it was it was in rough shape
when i first released it and then i
when i revised it again in 2016 um i was
actually pleasantly surprised that like
probably 95 of it i still stood by and
felt really good about
um the one the revision in 2016
i i kind of updated it because the
original version was slanted you know i
wrote it when i was like 26. so it was
still
slanted more towards like being a single
guy
going out and partying hooking up um i
wanted i wanted it to be kind of
relationship neutral you know so it's
like if you just want to get laid that's
fine
if you want to have like get married
that's also fine so i i revised it
to kind of you know speak to to
everybody and then the other thing the
thing that
really surprised me but models developed
a real following
among um among women and
among lgbt people and
um and so i kind of
edited that you know there were little
like simple examples or lines and stuff
here and there that i i kind of edited
just to like be applicable to a broader
audience because the
the central concepts of the book are
universal like the the things that make
ultimately drive human relationships and
make people happy in human relationships
and turn
people on are pretty universal
they're just expressed slightly
differently
based on gender and then they're
expressed slightly differently based on
sexual orientation and so i wanted to
just make the book
even though it's written for men i
wanted to make it as universal as
possible
right what do you think people are
giving too many [ __ ] about
that they shouldn't uh whatever's being
posted on twitter
fine fine that is
i think i can get universal agreement
from everybody yeah
period yeah full stop man thank you
so much for coming on uh this
will just will uh
november 9th and um dude i'm so
i'm so gassed for that awesome like
really
what a cool project to have worked on
and um yeah i can't wait for that to
come out
yeah me too man well look dude
markmanson.net
for all things you uh models
and subtle art and everything else will
be linked in the show notes below if
everyone wants to check that out
and what are your socials people want to
follow you on there
uh twitter is i am mark manson uh
instagram it's just mark manson
um and then i think facebook's mark
manson net everyone does anybody use
this anyone use facebook anymore
no nobody uses facebook anymore but um
old people use facebook
oh and i'm also on i'm also i have a
youtube channel now as well so i
i do um i do a few videos each month
so check that out brother thank you so
much
thank you and it was fun thank you very
much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed
peace